what is a man a miserable pile of holy
crap I forgot they were making this
Castlevania animated series on Netflix
license will not newest to me this
without super news III Newtons what is
super news what the heck am I talking
about I may in any case this is a brand
new to me I had heard the original
announcement but easy completely gone
out of my head but now oh whoa and I'm
guessing if you're what I ran this pump
this pump they released like a poster
and that's it just a poster why am i
this pumped over a poster mostly because
of what it reminded me of and also some
stuff I didn't realize first of all it's
animated which I think I did know but
you know in just that as a premise
I do love animation but that's not
enough to tell me in and of itself I
need to see something you need to get a
sense of style I get that from this
poster you know this poster made me
think of vampire hunter D and if they
can bring that feel to Castlevania well
first of all it's a perfect marriage in
the first place so they bring that look
and that feel to animation on Netflix
and there's big confirm to series and
the thing I didn't know Warren Ellis is
writing this Warren Ellis III have yet
to read anything by him that I didn't
like I ever read all this stuff I'm not
as well-read in general as I would like
to be there's very few writers whose
work I know more or less comprehensively
but my favorite completed run in the
comic book medium of all time is trans
metropolitan I love that thing so much I
love a more than Sandman I love me some
Sandman so I get a warrant Ellis is
writing this thing now is spelled evil
if you're a longtime follower on this
channel it might seem slightly odd that
I seem excited about this because I
badmouth video game movies before and I
will continue to I've actually even made
the argument and at this point I still
stand by it that video games can not
work as movies
I mean access what we see almost every
permutation we've seen ones that stuck
to the source materials deviated from
the source material we're based off
movies with the
Laure based off moving on Oh lor with
lousy directions with great directions
it doesn't seem to matter we keep
getting crap I'm not going to rehash all
my arguments as to why but if you go
back at the conversation and the
argument I had with my friend Paul a
couple months back on this very topic I
did concede that some of these things
might work as TV series now I don't
think either of us mention Netflix at
the time I think maybe we said something
you know HBO effect something like that
Netflix for whatever reason I don't
wasn't on my radar but the idea against
I a big part of why movies won't work I
said I wasn't going to rehash argument
I'll bring this up at least there are
two major reasons why I feel that video
game movies don't work one of them is
they don't have enough time because a
big part of why we and gamers really get
attached to these characters in these
stories and these settings is because we
spend so much time in them and that
amount of time is what allows these
settings to work the way that they do I
think a real great example of that is
Silent Hill the Silent Hill movie now
the Phantom movie is one of the better
video game movies out there it's still
not great though and it certainly
doesn't hit you the way those video
games it well the best ones in those
video games hit you and the reason is
when you play safe Silent Hill 2 which
most people will agree to the best one
of the franchise you are you're just
wandering that town in that setting for
hours through that fog and those
monsters you don't know when they're
going to come next you don't know what's
going on
you just have to dwell in it and it's
absorbing and it's immersive and because
you have to just exist in that space for
hours and hours and hours and in a movie
all they can do is sort of guide you by
hand and sort of take you on the
sightseeing tour of that and even though
the movie of Silent Hill realize that
visually incredibly well it couldn't be
as impactful because you're not these
atmosphere doesn't have the same time to
sink into your bones and really get to
you the way they did in the video game
but you do something that takes more
time like a series maybe we can make up
for the fact that I like is that one of
the reasons the movement mber working is
trying to cram
in two to two and a half hours the best
video game stories take advantage of one
of the things that video games have
which is a heck of a lot longer than two
hours to tell these stories now that
doesn't make gasoline on a bit of a
novel because Castlevania stories are
really bare-bones for the most part I
mean the stories are just here's the
castle fight your way through it until
you get to Dracula some of them do a
little bit more than that but it's
castling is not known especially for its
actual storyline it's more certainly um
and it's and it does like something like
Silent Hill have a ton of atmosphere and
a great feel to an actual nothing both
of a story not too much there but again
I think with a clever writer which
Warren Ellis most certainly is he can
take that and really build something
with it so it's funny I think right now
you're seeing it like for a little while
there for a couple of weeks you were
seeing how little things could set me
off in a bad way about movies like I
ranted just based off a motion poster
for ghosts in the show well you know
what little things can set me off in a
good direction too this is nothing but a
poster for show that who knows how long
it's going to be until we see it but you
know what it's enough to keep me excited
not just like hopeful excited by a
poster so I'll be keeping an eye on that
and I would like to think that it
succeeds and then that is what we see
for the future of video game adaptations
because stop with the movies the movies
don't work this could work so
Castlevania on Netflix what are your
thoughts about it what do you think
about this poster what do you think
about Warren else is involved what do
you think about any of it whatever your
thoughts are drop something out in the
comments let's talk about it don't
forget to Like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at Council of dese give a listen
to the council geeks podcast home of
ninety comics retrial available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned